[Musik]
franziska quadri tetraplegiker inside
einem gleitschirm unfall vor zehn jahren
ist sie vom hals an abwärts gelähmt kann
weder arme noch beine bewegen
klar ich komme sehr viel jünger und gibt
sich radio sagte so wird sich überlappen
und da soll ich friere zeit aber bei vox
dann halt einfach als audrey das ganze
umfeld war mal wieder zusammengeflickt
eine zwilling überleben aber endlich
auch das mein job sein
sie werden im laufe ja so am anfang ist
das seriös präsenz dem ob sie wie what
have ye done realisierter nur die
schmerzen immer stärker
und einfach die ganze hilflosigkeit und
die abhängigkeit ist ganz schwer zu mit
dem moskau und der sind die kitas oder
ob ich euer quiz dass es dass sich
aktive bist du unternehmen sondern das
wie im landesamt setzen und da bin ich
nicht in der lage dazu
und ich glaube wirklich an ihr mit laxey
meine erste begegnung mit franziska
quadri fand im jahr 2016 statt in ihrer
wohnung in zürich
es war auch eine erste begegnung mit den
unvorstellbaren schmerzen in ihren
gelähmten gliedern sich hin gerade
hälfte ziemlich stück in der innenstadt
versucht es mal klappt das gerne bilder
ja so super sexy
das sind spastiken das sind so viele
informationen sehen kann hat die
berührungen irgendwie nicht wirklich
verarbeiten und dann reagiert in kabul
mit das ist sehr schmerzhaft vor allem
die kombination mit einer
neuropathischen schmerzen wohnen ist das
ziemlich schmutzig
ist mit seinen kombination mit einer
neuropathischen schmerzen sehr schlimm
[Musik]
seit diesen aufnahmen sind knapp vier
jahre vergangen
nun hat sich franziska quasi wieder
gemeldet
es ging mir heute viel besser als damals
grund genug sie erneut zu besuchen
wie von geisterhand öffnet sich die tür
ihrer wohnung franziska quadri kann den
mechanismus verlieren bett aus mit dem
mund bedienen denn dort liegt sie noch
immer
regungslos
noch im bett macht franziska quasi ihren
ersten joint gegen den schmerz und die
spastik die berauschende wirkung des
cannabis spürt sie schon längst nicht
mehr psychisch oder körperlich also
mitte zu dem offensichtlich dass ich
viel mehr bewegen oder so ich bin
einfach viel stabiler so schnell
herunter ich nehme die ganze zeit noch
im sca wieder ziemlich zugleich so dass
ihr all und kurz mal viel besser als
noch vor drei jahren
und das weiß ich dass zug für disziplin
und dürfen unermüdlich suchten das mir
besser gott was sie kann hat wirklich
alle medikamente oder frau holle
medikament abgesetzt wildkräutern dass
mir das eine gut tut und dass ich jetzt
nicht einfach über jahre so viel
schmerzmittel und hat es mit dem
cannabis ersetzt und macht sehr viel in
eigenregie hier
es gilt franziska quasi besser doch die
schmerzen sind noch immer da
unvermindert am morgen hatte ich das
wort nötigen wir uns schmerzt danken und
irgendwie plante und holz gelernt mit
dem labor schwiegen wir einen kollegen
freund sie können am besten die gebiete
zu einigen versuch ist schließe dann
dann wären sie
vor diesem unfall arbeitete franziska
quasi in einem werbebüro sie hatte eine
beziehung reiste viel machte sport und
ging auf partys heute dominiert der
schmerz erleben so dass nikon bewege
mich gespielt dann aber auch mein ganzer
körper das nicht spüren ich habe nur
einen schmerz
trotz allem wird gerade durch das witzig
findet schon ein schönes wissen wo minis
sind und auch eine genau wie sie gegeben
man mich muss kraft setzen und die
wenigsten so aber das merkt sie dass da
einfach so aus ich weiß jetzt genau wo
das und das ist mit linken und ich liebe
wegen
franziska quadri ist 44 jahre alt und
lebt in einer mietwohnung in zürich
wipkingen ein leben im pflegeheim war
für sie nie eine option
sie beschäftigt zwei pflegefachfrauen
die jeweils zwei monate am stück tag und
nacht bei ihr leben
er kam für ein selbstbestimmtes leben
mit assistenz beiträgen hat sie bis vor
bundesgericht geführt sehr gut
sie sind sehr wichtig dass sie schön
ausgesandt
das ist noch schwierig dem also
eigentlich interessiert mich das niemand
so wirklich von ihm selber collins
spiegel kunst wegnehmen dann nehme ich
bin spiegel homburger sollte so die
gelähmten körperteile und so die wirkung
auf mich
die schnitte so ganz zumwinkel programms
seiner so schmerzt und wütend und halte
ich meine haare nicht trauen dem
rollstuhl drahtigen total kaputt und
brechen ab und ja das sind schon so
sagen das auch eitelkeit wohl nicht
durchführen können aber ich versuche das
irgendwie zu verdrängen und das auch
zeigen wie wichtig ihre sachen auf der
welt zum beispiel ja das mit frieden ist
und sind sie zufrieden
ich würde sagen ich bin ich jetzt wieder
sachen verloren ich will von dem seit
ständig von einer sache gut
ich kann machen was ich will nicht jeden
tag so italien bin ich das gerne hätte
ich kann meine energie für sachen
brauchen wir richtig sind weil ich mit
dem herz der bibel und das geht schon
wieder hat wo ich viel liebe haben und
ich kann das alles
[Musik]
einmal pro woche mit franziska quadri
unterstützt von einer kunsttherapeutin
dann entstehen solche selbstporträts
das ist so seit dem unfall bin ich schon
eher ruhig wurde inhalt oft überlegen
und für mich alleine ja kommt man
wahrscheinlich pinsel sich doch das
wirklich ist
das will ich einfach nur dass man mit
ihnen
ich bin in meiner familie gibt es genau
das was bedeutet ihnen das
das ist eigentlich das wichtigste für
mich
zum einen ist total schön dass ich bin
linken nützlich und brauchen also die
wenige funktionen bonino horn und
anderen ist dass die bilder einfach army
nikon seine erfahrungen und die letzten
eier kochen kann irgendwie verarbeiten
und sie schalten ort für mich zum mich
selbst therapieren
[Musik]
immer am jahrestag ihres unfalls
entsteht ein neues selbstporträt es
geschah am 17 mai 2009 beim starten ließ
eine windboe franziskas kleidchen ein
paar meter in die höhe
sie stolperte und stürzte kopfüber in
eine wiese beim aufprall brach ihre
hausherren säule ganz am anfang war die
nummer bringt also keine hoffnungen
dort trug sie und noch erwarteten dass
irgendwo in der wird gab sich wortkarg
die augen der taktieren irgendwann wird
es dann zur eifersucht oder wie die
künstler durch das sind wirklich so
verschiedene gefühlsebene womit dort
gebaut und hütet sodass sie heißt aber
ich glaube ich ärgere mich nicht darüber
dadurch muss das wirklich einfach hinter
mir und setzen so wie es ist das mache
ich mir wirklich krank fallen jahrestage
10 selbstportraits in gedenken an ihren
unfall mit den jahren sind alle ihre
bilder freundlicher geworden
die 165 wir das setup symbolisieren das
kann ich schon jetzt so verstanden dass
man hat man gespürt verschreckte wenn es
nicht im rollstuhl sind ja sie schaut
einfach schwierig wenn man merkt dass
man so einen musste ich mich natürlich
schon bewusst dass ich zu der elektro
rollstuhl wollen und dass ich dass ich
oben das spiel als die anderen aber eine
blüte so verschreckt auf einem reagieren
so machen wir das
[Musik]
unverstanden fühlt sich franziska quasi
auch wenn es um cannabis geht für sie
ein unverzichtbares heilmittel für die
gesellschaft eine droge
aus diesem grund engagiert sie sich als
präsidentin für madcon den medical
cannabis verein schweiz
er setzt sich für die anliegen von
menschen ein die cannabis medizinisch
anwenden
ja froh dass ich da geblieben bin ich
schon über 120 damit mache da war's dann
alle kohlemine fähigkeiten und freunden
aus grafikern braucht man jetzt umsetzen
und so viele schrieben das machen spaß
und webseite betreuer und alles was aus
start bin ich war vorderster front
hallo simon
wie findest du es fragezeichen
vielleicht kann ich den text auch
weglassen und du schreibst ihn
darunter
[Musik]
und merkel haben oder
ich begrüße sie herzlich zum patienten
schön dass sie da sind hauptsächlich
kinder die runde aber schaut bitte im
herbstlichen wetter haben viele
schmerzen können öko
als präsidentin von madcon leitet
franziska quasi auch die monatlichen
patienten treffen in zürich
der verein fordert straffreiheit für
patientinnen und patienten
denn sie alle hier leben in ständiger
angst vor dem eingreifen der behörde
ihre forderung an die aktuelle revision
des betäubungsmittelgesetzes der
gemeinschaftlich organisierte cannabis
eigenanbau diese sei im moment die
einzige möglichkeit zur bahre und
hochstehende cannabis medikamente zu
erhalten
es ist so dass es gott letzten
parlamentswahlen sie sind und ich sind
jetzt wohl raus muss ausgesetzt werden
politiker im parlament wo krone bis zum
befürworter hat man eine rolle die
medien verschickt und normal aufmerksam
machen dass die website wisse dass
mieter sind also wo franziska 26 jahre
als total überrascht mit ihrem power wo
sie entwickelt wie sie hätte frau dort
gefunden wo plötzlich gemerkt ich habe
die apps betrag zu der gesellschaft will
vorher ich sie eigentlich relativ zu und
flacht lagen im bett vor allem
medikament betreut und als präsidentin
ist sie sowohl motor und gleichzeitig
auch für viele andere patienten als
riese vorbild wie man sie schicksal
wieder kasse bringen einer die sich
franziska quasi zum vorbild genommen hat
ist simon wenigsten verdient mit 23 an
multipler sklerose erkrankt ist ja links
von ihrem mann sehr schlechte momente
mit das extrem oft um das bin von
kortison für alle medikamente und hätte
das fatale gibt ja ich habe es mir
glaube das ist ja stimmen 16 militärisch
zu erste förderlizenz weiter und bestach
ist nicht der andere haben wir nicht
viele medikamente absetzen
natürlich immer noch therapien zur
behandlung der ms
aber alle die ihr medikament wirklich
sind total ersetzt
ihre medikamente und die cannabisblüten
zum rauchen beschafft sich franziska
quasi illegal denn sie kann auch tropfen
die sie mit einer ausnahmebewilligung
von ihrem arzt erhält wirken viel zu
schwach ich kann mit dem rollstuhl
natürlich schon als glück dass das das
akzeptiert wird
ich mache mir wirklich nicht zu sorgen
dass sich das irgendwie nicht zu denken
also gar nicht muss danach der
öffentlichkeit konsumieren
im winter sind franziskus schmerzen
immer besonders heftig darum flieht sie
seit fünf jahren jeweils ende oktober
nach teneriffa
begleitet von ihren eltern die sie
bedingungslos unterstützen erzählte was
würdest du dann machen wir das eben
aber es muss es dann vielleicht
probieren
in spanien ist in einheimischen der
besitz von cannabis für den persönlichen
gebrauch erlaubt
touristen wie die quadress allerdings
bewegen sich in einer rechtlichen
grauzone
weltkrieg vor dem cannabis beteiligen
tochter und hat jetzt schon einiges
dritter klasse und muss sagen ja warum
mit mythos braucht für medizinische
ursachen sind wir für einen schönen
abend machen
nicht nur die familie unterstützt
franziska quadri auch ihre freunde haben
wir nach dem unfall ausnahmslos die
treue gehalten aber franziskus unfall
war auch für ihr umwelt eine
herausforderung ich habe mich kennt bin
im umgang bin ich irgendwie versuchen ja
nie falsch ist sagte zum beispiel oder
ausgeschlossen habe ich mich irgendwie
irgendwann richtig machen oder
körperlich erlebnis und ich will
versuchen zum gau aber es gehört im
prinzip auch die ständig grünschnitt und
ich bin dann spüren ich bitte nicht
bekämpft und ja aber das hat sich all
das hat land braucht aber das hat sich
unterdessen
sind weniger die inzwischen ist jede
zweite assistentin aus der slowakei
wieder bei franziska quasi eingezogen
und kocht für sie und ihre langjährigen
freunde in ihrer wohnung ist manchmal zu
wie in einem bienenhaus sagt franziska
quadri und sie mittendrin sie so liebt
und dass ich einfach für mich stärker
gemacht alles für sie das workout und es
gibt sie auch ständig das ist so
verhalte wichtig ist dass man keine zeit
miteinander verbringen und das
gegenseitig lernen
auch wenn sie einen großen freundeskreis
und eine unterstützende familie hat
franziska quadri fühlt sich oft einsam
und sehnt sich nach einer beziehung
ansonsten aber ich liebe sie ein gutes
leben
happy end ist eigentlich so
vorgeschrieben will ich jetzt gelernt
toni deller letzter zeit mit der
schwierigen situation und mit dem
rollstuhl haben jährigen das neues labor
neue aufgaben finden und finde ich sehr
gut geschafft und ich bin für die zweite
street nichts klappt und das ist
eigentlich vielleicht nicht so eines
happy ends ezb mit umbenennung schluss
neugier in den zune untergang gerettet
aber das würde sehr gut zu mir passt das
happy end vor mir fehlen wird sie dass
sich trotz der schwierigen situation und
ich drehe bin es schönes lager geführt
haben das trainingslager geführt haben
viele freunde kochen und ich hoffe nur
einiges bewegen
[Musik]